Today, we're gonna make a keg out of a watermelon.
Place a nice-sized watermelon on a flat surface and remove the top.
Now, cut in deep and loosen up the fruit inside,...
...then with a large spoon, scoop out most of the insides,...
...leaving just enough to help flavor whatever beverage you decide to put inside.
After we have the melon hollowed out, it's ready to tap.
And then we'll get our beverages going.
Cut a hole about half the size of the tap directly into the watermelon.
Pop it out with your finger and clear out any fruit.
Be careful not to make it too large,...
...as you want it to be a very tight fit to form a seal.
After the hole was ready, I took my valve and slowly worked it into the melon.
Looks like we're ready to go.
Fill up the watermelon with lots of ice to keep things chilled...
...and then pour beverage of your choice.